[Musique]
changer le monde cette semaine le
recyclage du plastique qu'on en parle
avec jocelyne doucet qui dirige pire
wade
bonsoir monsieur doucet sans nous
révéler tous vos secrets industriels
c'est quoi exactement pire web et
comment votre technologie se démarque
matière or il tout d'abord c'est une
plateforme électrique qui utilise les
micro ondes un peu comme celle qu'ont à
la maison le four micro-ondes échappe
permet de briser les molécules de clarté
et les ramener à leur forme originale de
base est pas qu on a retrouvé les
molécules de base on peut les réutiliser
pour refaire soit des places et qu'il en
fait que au plastique originale où le
réintroduire vin dans des nouveaux
produits ok et c'est quoi la petite
histoire de pire wade voit la petite
soixantaine d'années à travailler sur un
problème qui nous anime tous les jours
de france des plastiques c'est un
problème qui était grand champ et qui
était présent une fin d'année qu'il est
encore plus aujourd'hui et c'est d'eux
que nous un damné développé une
technologie industrielle donc ça demande
des moyens considérables construire des
prototypes démontrer la technologie que
maintenant on en est à l'étape de
vraiment du déploiement industriel et
puis ben on a fait quand même des
progrès substantiels de puissants et
puis le cap industriel et là on va vous
suivre de près on a vu vous aimerez pas
ma question là mais je voulais pourrait
quand même rapport accablant récemment
sur une entreprise québécoise qui
s'appelle ou pour ne pas la nommer
qui dit qu'il ya aussi une technologie
de recyclage du plastique mais le
rapport dit que ça ne vaut rien comment
on peut être certain de votre côté que
tout est au point
c'est évidemment de toutes sortes de
technologies qui existent sur le marché
bon look en particulier travaillé sur un
certain type de classiques nous on
travaille sur les déplacés par addition
comme le polystyrène faites-vous c'est
je peux pas parler pour les autres mais
quand nous évidemment on a des
partenariats cela dit on a travaillé
avec des dés
et on a toute une équipe de pieds que je
dis d'ingénieurs on a des publications
scientifiques ont été faits aux vertus à
angie par la communauté scientifique
et puis ben dernièrement on fait des
partenariats essayait long on a produit
du produit on a fait des échantillons
réel avec des vrais clients non il ya
quelque chose de changé d'une usine qui
tourne en est à valleyfield ont quelque
chose à voir pour vous c'est très clair
vous avez tout à fait confiance en votre
produit pilar vous venez de conclure
avec michelin une entente parlez nous de
cette entente là une chance et c'est
amusant parce que c'est un leader
mondial dans les matériaux n'ont qu'eux
ils ont un focus très fort sur la
durabilité donc ils veulent développer
des matériaux durables
tintin et nous on se gare un peu alors
procéder c'est que dans les élastomères
qu'on retrouve dans les pneus il ya
aussi des élastomères synthétique
excuses élastomère synthétique leur
utilisent les troupes et les produits
chimiques de base qui sont reproduits
par notre technologie
donc ça devient de façon son voeu de
s'approvisionner en matière première à
partir des déchets plastiques et donc
l'objectif du partenariat avec michelin
effectivement c'est de mettre cette
technologie là dedans une réussie de
bénéficier de l'expertisé industrielle
du groupe michelin depuis de générer des
données pour est capable d'allier au
fond des choses valider la performance
technologique la performance
environnementale la performance
économique et à quels autres débouchés
khalip ne pourrait-on pas ainsi plus la
matière que vous pouvez recyclées mais
le podium c'est notre première plate
forme c'est un matériau très intéressant
pour nous et puis donc hilario sortes
d'applications à qui en résultent du
printemps dans les emballages septembre
à l'âge où on arrive au bureau par
exemple mais aussi ont pu utiliser ce
mot d'un merle pour trafiquer les cramer
par exemple la bsa qui forme et pour
tourner parce qu'il ya toute une
panoplie d'applications qui colle
d'amener beaucoup plus circulaire
l'arrêt des technologies comme les
nôtres qu'on appelle des polymérisation
l'état souvent on dit qu'on perd en
qualité à chaque fois qu'on recycle
est-ce que des vieux pots de yogourt ou
des contenants à sushis par exemple
pourrait redevenir des contenants de
qualité alimentaire au bout du processus
absolument c'est que évidemment les
procédés mécaniques et auquel on pense
le centre lavage
voyager c'est sûr on a fait que la
qualité du produit
ici on arrive avec une technologie qu'on
appelle des risques la chine et on joue
à mon niveau des molécules ce qui fait
que au terme de ce processus là on
obtient un produit réactif qui hydrate 6
qui serait obtenu par des sources vierge
et dont carey a annoncé ces molécules
lançant pauvres à déplacer des produits
bain et on peut pas voir leurs
différentes
donc c'est sûr chez des processus un
petit peu plus invasif en dessous plus
énergivores on veut mais à la fin la
valeur et les idées qu'il fait avec du
liège avec - vous changer le monde à
votre façon jocelyn douce et merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup merci bien